welcome Penn sorry Oh for this head to
this video and it's a calc on that one
Sam I am at c5 in my seriously on the
ICC but i really forget everything that
i present them what was the correct move
now Knight to d7 Knight to c6 okay let's
just down make it up as we go along here
Queen a five maybe a three takes takes
Queen d4 intending be form maybe this is
serve a problem
yeah before what an annoying more
Queen a three I can play I'm a three
takes takes Queen d4 rook c8 be for
Green a three this is what I'm
calculating maybe this is complete
nonsense but what about this tending
night f5 maybe I can do that a
three-night f5 before I can take III I
hope now is playing this very quickly
why why can I not take yeah well this is
great now guy you've spent 20 seconds to
to get to this position and I really
don't like her why its position at all
let's let's see
95 this your idea maybe I'm not well
developed well developed pratik on c5
what what they'll on 95 yard I
development is really a catastrophe
let's play that cool 16 I can even think
about taking you five now I can think
about it i'm not saying that I'm playing
it but I can think about it I can
actually I can I can do that why not
takes takes c6 c7 is just the check king
of eight Bishop c6 hmm I could take c7
and c3 it's really really good for Black
Knight b8 was my initial idea but why
not is it sits perfectly all right this
is taking and so honest is not so not
much of a problem I can play Bishop e7 e
oh yeah okay with this now is just just
good for black
I'm pulling up anyway I'm not upon up
anyway but i probably will be just this
neat yeah people are simply quicker than
me they play all those far-reaching
decisions instantly it must be great
great to be a such a good player Bishop
before night a 2 or what and don't get
it
yeah see 6th sem is a weakness it's not
not an asset
no it's um technically still a bit a bit
just a bit of a problem we had
Tommy difficult really difficult yeah
probably i played some inaccurate move
before i really can't believe that this
should be you're working for white guard
especial can move of course jack
really strange the skin
yeah no I'm threatening to get this
Bishop out mm okay cannot think all day
here with us this is not not a problem I
think he's playing every every important
move instantly anyway so
yeah 30 seconds this is the problem yeah
I've got two extra points but how to win
this especially if you blunder one of
them yeah
yeah crap absolutely crap is can easily
play on now and I have very little
chance to to do anything can even allow
this netting check check check check
yeah the time I mean how will you ever
lose the position it's not possible
ready check
check
try for pre-move care for we probably
play 92 what check check this way is not
winning on time check scale me not
surprising save really expected to to
lose some time yeah I got lots of time
in this difficult position here yeah
somewhere around here this is a matter
of some exact moves and I think like
should be it should be good Bishop b2 we
are Bishop t2 sins yeah that was already
about two minutes down so I couldn't
really invest much more time here Bishop
t2 is much stronger yeah adhered
actually turned upside down 92 93 is
better now but he played everything
instantly anyway not caring if it's a
good move or whatever you know this is
tricky yeah this is actually quite okay
according to come out about a draw and
this is bad this is of course
exceptionally dead
this is not such an easy win in a blitz
game I instantly blundered blundered 95
of course which he didn't play I mean
why now I can I can prevent it again I
know f6 but okay no no time at all okay
I'm yet no no it's the draw nothing
nothing much the 2d pawns are worthless
snow are meaningful extra porn anymore
yeah a bit of a weird game thanks for
watching